you're watching c-span 3 history
we continue our look at the pentagon
papers now with the man who leaked them
to the press in 1971
daniel ellsberg mr ellsberg spoke in
2001
on the 30th anniversary of that event
this is about an hour
and in that time i hope to focus on just
one of the many aspects that one could
that will be covered today that's the
pentagon papers
can you hear me that's right can you
hear me
how is it back there okay
i want to talk about the pentagon
pentagon papers as leak
or unauthorized disclosure i first heard
this phrase unauthorized disclosure
in connection with the bill that was
passed by both houses of congress
last fall for the first time
criminalizing
uh unauthorized disclosure and i
immediately
which was fortunately and unexpectedly
vetoed by
president clinton unexpectedly because
his own attorney general janet reno has
supported the bill in its final form
that was passed
i immediately liked the word
unauthorized disclosure because i've
never really liked the word leak
same little pejorative demeaning didn't
sound good didn't have the ring that it
had for me
and my wife has especially always
disliked me being called a leaker
she she felt it made me sound
incontinent
so i'm an undisclosed just i'm an
unauthorized disclosure
from now on the question then i'd like
to address is
what can we learn from this experience
from the experience of the last 30 or 50
years
about the role of unauthorized
disclosure
in this country in the world and above
all in a democratic republic and
one that means to remain so
when i was on trial and afterwards when
i was lecturing i had occasion very
often to quote
a statement made after he was in office
by james madison the author
of the first amendment i'm sure you all
heard it but it really deserves
repeating
and pondering over and over again
knowledge
will forever govern ignorance
and a people who mean to be their own
governors must arm themselves with the
power
that knowledge gives popular government
without popular information or the means
of acquiring it
is but the prologue to a farce or a
tragedy
or perhaps both
now we've seen farce a lot of it in
watergate
or rand gate we've seen the plumbers
we've seen tragedies certainly and
primarily
not tragedy for america though it was a
tragedy
more like a crime a tragedy for vietnam
that we imposed on vietnam from the very
beginning of that conflict in our
support of the french
vietnam war of course was not only an
unwinnable war as i'd come to see by
66 or 67 in vietnam
which was enough for me and many others
to try to work against it
from inside when i read the earliest
portions of the pentagon papers which
were the last that i read just in
september of 1969
by which time i would say i had already
been committed for year
two years at least for getting us out of
vietnam
when i read the earliest pages i
realized the volumes
um i realized that i was reading not
just the record of a tragic
mistake but of a colonial war
in which the united states had been a
participant from its earliest position
in the truly tragic decision made
by franklin roosevelt in the last months
of his life and persisted in by harry
truman
to support the french in their
determination to reconquer
their colonial empire in indochina and
elsewhere
that was tragic at those days you might
say with the un charter's recognition
of colonial rule
as a legitimate form of rule recognized
not not
criminalized be hard to say that was a
crime at that time
but we can judge it morally politically
in various ways
in many ways in any case what i learned
when i read that in september of 69 very
late in the game for me
was that this was not only a war that we
couldn't win
we could not defeat the people fighting
for
independence from foreign rule they
would not be defeated by anything we
could do they would not give up
they would not give up against us any
more than the french
but it was a war that we had no right to
win a war we should not win a war we
should not be in
and that killing in that war mostly
financed by us
was unjustifiable homicide and that
should be ended
as soon as possible not
gracefully not saving our face
as i would have been willing to do to
some degree before 67
or 68 but as soon as possible and i had
no illusions that that would be easy
but that was one of the things that
drove me in other words having written
riv having read these papers which for
me
were authorized the disclosure to me was
an authorized disclosure
i was a consultant at that point for the
rand corporation but one trusted
to keep its secrets no matter how much i
disagreed
and i had been tested on that many many
times
i didn't get those secrets because they
just thought
they hoped i would keep them secret
anyone
associated with me knew that i was one
of those
who would keep certain kinds of
information
about planning about estimates about
proposals
from unauthorized persons meaning not
just unauthorized persons let me come
back to that
but specifically from the american
public
from congress from political rivals in
most cases this
the issue didn't even arise of concern
whether i would keep them from the
russians or the vietnamese
in most cases we were reading about
things that the russians and vietnamese
had been told directly by
us that is by our leaders threats that
were made that were no secret
to our opponents actions
attacks on north vietnam attacks on
cambodia and tax on laws that were no
secret
from the people under the bombs were
secret only
from the american people and from
congress and in some cases that secret
has an ironic aspect to it when william
beecher of the new york times revealed
that we were bombing cambodia
one might say it ceased to be secret
not so it was not regarded as a fact
as a happening as an experienced by the
american public for many years
afterwards
until a leak a real leak occurred that
was because the evening of beecher's
announcement
the defense department simply said not
even dignify with a white house denial
the defense department just said
routinely that story's wrong
it's not happening and so it wasn't
happening
in a period when presidents were
believed or thought
maybe not to tell everything maybe to be
a little misleading a little
exaggerating sometimes
but not to lie which was a mistake
presidents do all those things they
conceal they cover all officials do
congressmen do it's part of the game
lawyers do
they also lie i'm talking about
presidents now and the people who work
for them
so i had uh been known for
five years at that point really ten
years
to be reliable in keeping secrets
that i strongly disagreed with in the
policy that i thought were bad
terrible even disastrous which is the
way i felt about our nuclear war
planning
disastrous and yet anyone around me knew
i was one of those who could be given
such secrets i didn't have to agree with
the policy
i would keep it that's the way i was
until 69. now
for the first time to perceive that this
uh
what i was reading about was not just
dangerous
and costly and tragic all of which it
was
but something close to murder and i
don't use that word
rhetorically unjustifiable homicide let
the lawyers tell me
what the best way of describing that is
but killing it should not go on
that did affect my sense of what it was
worth doing
for me personally to stop it but i had a
much stronger
uh incentive at that very time than that
which caused the
uh which was which was absolutely
crucial
i was given information because i had
worked on vietnam options
in the beginning of the year for henry
kissinger working for kiss
nixon in fact i had drafted a set of
alternative options and drafted a set of
questions
after that called national security
study memorandum 1 to be given
and had gone over the answers for the
president for that reason i was given a
piece of information with my top secret
clearance by someone
who had been in the white house and uh
left
in the fall of 1961.
in the fall of 1961 mort halpern told me
because of my background
and his knowledge of my reliability
which was quite justified
what option nixon had chosen
and it wasn't actually one of the ones i
had put in the set
interestingly it it's not in common as
the pentagon papers show
president's very commonly end up with a
policy that is not
really correspond to any one of the
alternatives that any agency gave him
and that was true in this case what
nixon had chosen i was told
was a policy of secret threats of
escalation
just like the ones that johnson had
secretly given
uh lg men in the summer of 1964 during a
campaign when he gave absolutely the
opposite impression
nixon was again making secret threats of
escalation despite
the failure of bombs 3.2 million tons of
bombs by that time to bring them to
their heels
he thought the threats of even greater
escalation hanoi binding of
invasions would cause them to
not surrender not give in but to accept
what he thought of as a compromise
which they would have seen as defeat the
permanent exclusion
of the leaders of the independence
movement
communists from government in saigon
the permanent uh renunciation of
unification
of vietnam as one
so it was certain that they would not
accept those terms
i believe from my study of the pentagon
papers in my experience the threats
would be carried out
they weren't bluffs i believe that i
believed that they would not
win the war or end the war
again from experience including my
experience in vietnam
facing people that gave me a very strong
impression they
wouldn't quit no matter how many of them
we killed
um so the war would just be longer and
bigger
i saw then a prolongation under a
president who'd been elected to endure
of the war of a pattern that led us into
endless war
previously under previous presidents
this was
very almost unique information
i wasn't shared by people in the
anti-war movement people who ended the
war it was just from mort halpern
as he said uh i told everybody that who
would listen
he told me you were the one i said you
were the one he said who listened
and believed him i knew his access i
know his reliability
and i where most people as mort said
would have found that just
incredible nixon couldn't be doing that
and i would say by the way the
journalists and historical community has
to a large extent found my account of
this
incredible ever since because i didn't
have documents to prove it
larry berman a very good historian of
the johnson era
and is now coming out with a book in
august i think called no peace no honor
in which he's dazzled me by having found
documents
that i would say do demonstrate this
thesis at last i've never seen them
before
she's really collected them that's 30
years later
i was concerned that i didn't have the
documents not as concerned as i should
have been
the truth is looking back after the
pentagon papers
i've never really been believed or
convinced anybody of what i was saying
about policy
most of it being unfamiliar and not
people something people didn't want to
believe
without documents if i'd had those
documents
at the time mort himself didn't have
them he'd been shown documents that he
wasn't
supposed to see as the deputy to
kissinger
another deputy showed him documents that
had been withheld from ward himself
threats deliberately directly delivered
to the russians through
to brennan he didn't have documents to
give me any he might or might not have
shown to them to me if in that mood at
that time he had shown them to me or had
access to them
i certainly would have put those out
rather than the pentagon papers i would
not have spent the time
however important the pentagon papers
history were
i was concerned with stop avoiding
escalation
and stopping the war the pentagon papers
had obvious defects obvious to me as
well as to everyone else
as an instrument for ending the war they
could illuminate the war to other
people and maybe increase their disgust
with it but
they didn't prove what nixon was doing
my assertion was that nixon was doing
what essentially truman but in
particular
and eisenhower in the 50s but in
particular uh
kennedy and johnson had done he was
still doing it
and all the pentagon papers could do for
that message which was my message that i
put out to congressman
in person to everybody letters to the
editor
all the pentagon papers could do which
was something was to say well it's
happened before
you may think it's hard to believe that
a man would be so reckless and so mad is
to
expand or having been told what the
costs would be and how hopeless it was
but four presidents before did it so
maybe you should entertain that
possibility
you might find it hard to believe that a
president who's been elected one way
would simply lie remember that nixon
wasn't
clearly lying at this time he did expect
to end the war
but he expected to do it by threats that
would work and if necessary by
escalation
i thought that his sincere belief was
extremely misguided
and does not do his reputation as a
statesman or henry kissinger's which
does remain
any credit it was foolish reckless
uninformed but the main thing was
not to expose that about him but to end
the war
in fact i thought the pentagon papers in
particular
might encourage republican richard nixon
as a
res new president to
uncommit himself from what mort had said
he was privately doing
he hadn't yet announced it in september
my real hope in my initial copying the
pentagon papers for which
tony russo was absolutely crucial uh in
finding a xerox machine helping me
getting this started fast
was to release this record of democratic
recklessness and duplicity
and encourage nixon to reconsider
and think uh as some of his advisers
like laird and rogers were urging him to
do his secretary of state and secretary
of defense
do what they said he should do not what
he and his heart felt and
kissinger felt and blame the war on the
democrats
and say it's a lost cause it was a noble
cause but it was a lost cause
they screwed it up i have no choice but
to cut the losses and get out
that's what i hoped it might do i think
that was a reasonable hope i didn't have
any assurance
but it was unreasonable in terms of
nixon's actually actual commitment
i now realize that if i put that out in
69 as i planned to do and tried to do
through fulbright
it would have had no effect on nixon and
the war even in 71
the main reaction in the white house was
elation
that this information was out it made
the democrats look bad
and the tapes show that very clearly
they're all gloating
how this would put the democrats at each
other's throats and it made the
democrats and it showed that nixon
hadn't started the war etc etc
and of course it didn't prove that the
that nixon
was continuing the policy and that was a
reaction that didn't surprise me at all
when i read the tapes i thought
might well do that what i didn't realize
in 69 was
how committed nixon was having been vice
president
during a major crucial stage including
the diane benfoor
of our earlier involvement he didn't
think he had inherited that war he
thought it was his war and eisenhower's
war it was a good war and should be one
and he thought he knew a way to do it
but it was a way that the public by 69
would not endorse
he knew that so it must be kept secret
from them
therefore in even as late as 71 the plan
had not totally been carried out
a hemorrhage of secrets even about the
past carried the
possible risk that it would continue
there would be more secrets
about nixon documents about nixon which
unfortunately i didn't have much of
he knew i had some national security
study memorandum one
like all government officials leaving
office i had with me the stuff i'd
worked on
uh which is to say that uh i would say
every i don't know how many officials
are in this audience and to a first
approximation
every but let's say 90 percent of
government officials are holding
documents
um that are forbidden they are forbidden
to hold by the rules
that and the promises they've made for
their memoirs to go against
republican rivals i mean i'm sorry
professional rivals
and so forth not all rivals are
republican
and they're not all from a different
party um
the um they are not
breaking the law we have
no official secrets act unlike virtually
every other country
none has ever been passed by congress
until last november
and that was vetoed i was very struck to
see the
editorials that came out very properly
and
uh quickly seeing where i am i'll make a
different
prediction now i'm gonna go five more
minutes and take ten minutes for
questions okay
um
it was actually in the course of that
editorial those editorials most of which
came out after the law had been passed a
little
little late and when a veto was not
expected
had excellent editorials in the times
the post and elsewhere in the country
mentioning for the first time i remember
seeing in print
that we have no official secrets act and
this would be the first
and it would be bad i'd never seen that
little point which tony and i
were anxious to make during the trial we
didn't feel i don't think that it was
really adequately brought out during the
trial
the fact that our trial our prosecution
for copying and possessing unauthorized
copies as i say what
every official does actually but never
been tried before
and then there was a boston grand jury
working on the distribution
the leak part of it that would have been
the first prosecution for a revelation
the first ever what was not appreciated
was
that this was as unprecedented a
prosecution
as the injunctions before the supreme
court were unprecedented
in junctions the two were had
no president and both for the same
reason the first amendment
and which reflected the views that i
just
said to you from george madison the
author of the first amendment that there
must not be an official secrets act
if in benjamin franklin's words we want
to keep this a republic
uh that the fact is unauthorized
disclosure
uh has is ambiguous unauthorized
disclosures occur within the system
every minute of every hour giving stuff
to
people that taught secrets to people
secrets to people that your boss has not
told you to give
but in course of getting the job done
you share that information
it's against the rules it happens
constantly it's part of the way the
system works
unauthorized discussions to the press
and congress happen
every day or every other day they're not
truly unauthorized they really just
they're against the rules
they are not authorized by the head of
an agency they are classified
information
but it reflects nearly the decentralized
nature
of necessarily decentralized nature of
the secrecy process and i should say the
management of information
within the government so
in other words public affairs officers
officials of every kind even low-level
people
are trusted in their job will never
jeopardize their job
by making disclosures that in their
judgment they understand their bosses
will like made
in fact that was really i understand why
the why the law was vetoed
it was pointed out by strobe talbot to
clinton at the last minute this would
make criminals
out of our public affairs officers
almost every day they are it's not a
joke they are selectively putting out
classified information
there is no leeway in that for the in
the rules for that
but it's necessary and of course they do
it it's necessary to fool the public
to focus their attention on this rather
than that to to
support this position rather than that
one to affect the budget so we
we've got to revise this this rule a
little bit
i'm talking about disclosures that are
really unauthorized
would not be approved by the president
or the head of an agency
if they were submitted for their for
their permission
and those are the disclosures that most
need
disclosing remember the reason the
president doesn't want it out i'm
postulating
a large class of cases has nothing to do
with keeping it from
the enemy over there the vietnamese
soviets or whoever we may indeed be
talking about things that we have
directly delivered to the soviets or the
vietnamese in the way of threats
they must not go to the public they
would not be authorized and
to think in any system of submitting
them for authorization
misses their very nature to mention
another fond of the republic
tom payne in his first book common sense
he said
maybe a little extremely but he said
this nations
should have no secrets for the secrets
of courts
are ever their defects now it's defects
it's crimes failures errors
recklessness breaking of treaties
defects like that
where lives are at stake that are
exactly what must be in the hands of
congress
the public the voters and perhaps the
courts
if we are to be protected from reckless
and illegal actions that the president
has decided in his opinion are good for
the national interest in his interest
unauthorized disclosures are the hard
blood
of democracy and of a democratic
republic
it is not the case that we need new laws
criminalizing these for the first time
to have less unauthorized disclosures i
would say
we need many more such unauthorized
disclosures
like the pentagon papers and like the
documents i would have put out
if i had had them looking back i should
have put them out and i would have put
them out and public needed those a lot
more than the pentagon papers
i can look back to my own experience
when we come to the 1964 65 items of the
pentagon papers we are looking at
documents
all of which were in my safe with my
authorized position
in the pentagon when i was special
assistant to the assistant secretary of
state of defense
in 1964-65
i knew that everything being put out
about the tonkin gulf every aspect that
was being relayed about the tonkin gulf
incidents
was a conscious lie partly to protect
intelligence operations which were not
only illegal but terribly improved
and should never have been done which
were as foolish and progressive as let's
say
and illegal as the bay of pigs which
should have been disclosed
before it happened from every point of
view i also knew
i had written drafts myself which of
course i have being a former government
official
of speeches for mcnamara telling the
true number of troops
that were being sent to vietnam in 65 as
an addition to the 75 000 we already had
that the true number which i had in my
draft
was a hundred thousand and i listened to
the president give and said to that
speech
the figure 50 000. a day later
lying directly lying to the public i had
faiths full of documents of such uh
insane wrong criminal and deceptive
deceptive as the least of it they were
deceptive because
they were so foolish and would never
have gotten support from an electorate
that had just voted
uh johnson in by the largest landslide
in history
to avoid escalation that they feared
under goldwater so we had a hoax of an
election
the difference between the two
candidates was in was presented as night
and day
goldwater and johnson in fact known to a
thousand people inside if not more
they were very similar and the public
was about to get
bombing of vietnam whichever one they
voted for
those two now i did not put any of that
information out
i don't need to point fingers at
mcnamara or whoever else
whoever who may have have thought about
the policy even more
uh wisely than i did people like george
ball who were clearly against it at that
point
clark clifford later who was more
clearly against than i was at that point
knew more about it
i don't need to point fingers at them
for not putting it out i can say
i didn't put it out and in my lowly form
in which my category i was a beginner
here i was no part of a policy maker
never even became one in that year
i was like a clerk i was like a
secretary
but i knew what i was reading and i knew
where i would head
i could have given that information to
morris as he pointed out to me
or groaning and as moore said if you've
given us that information he said to me
in 71
in 64 the tonkin gulf resolution would
never have gotten out of committee
and if it got out it would never have
passed but the drunken gulf resolution
is just a resolution he could have
gotten it under other circumstances
he uh he could have done without it but
later so i didn't blame myself too much
when morris told me that
years later i reflected but wait duncan
golf is august 4th
by september i had a safe full of stuff
like that about where we were going
the likelihood of bombing the like the
fact that
not only was this a terribly reckless
policy but we had a candidate who was
totally
lying about it in fact two because even
goldwater knew of these plans and four
bore to mention them
he ran on a he ran proposing a plan
that he knew was in the works anyway so
that's how democracy was working given
our secrecy system
worked again and again all right i just
say i believe
without being grandiose here about uh
not that i could have ended the war i
believe
the documents in my possession could
have averted that war
had i revealed them that is what i
should have done that's what i wish i'd
done
of course i didn't think of it i don't
have to tax myself
with um to that degree of
moral guilt because like all my
colleagues it just didn't occur to me to
do such a thing
but i would hope it would i know it
would have occurred to me a few years
later
and i would hope it would occur to other
people past the
after the pentagon papers and watergate
and iran gate
and the other examples they've had in
short
are modern pentagon papers do they exist
then are they needed
and should they be put out at risk the
risk is inescapable
with or without a law i would say i have
no doubt whatever
that at this moment i'll finish in one
minute i have no doubt whatever
that there are people in this government
who believe
right now in the republican
administration executive branch
that the course of this administration
toward abandoning the abm treaty
is catastrophic and that every
reassurance
put diplomatically in terms of
proliferation in terms of a nuclear arms
race
and that every reassurance given to us
by the officials in this government
is contradicted by official documents
i would put to them they should consider
consider sharing those documents with
congress
at whatever cost to themselves because a
world is at stake
our policy under clinton and now pursued
under bush in colombia
is as foolish as counterproductive as
crazy
as vietnam i am sure there are people in
the administration who know that and
have documents that would support it
i call on them to do what i should have
done in 64 and did not do
go to congress tell the truth with
documents
it can save a lot of lives
we have about 15 minutes for questions
and what i'd ask is that uh
many of you in here are panelists if you
would hold back and allow the audience
and then please if you have a question
go to the mics because this is being
recorded and will recognize
you at the microphones so thank you
my name is paul mann i'm a reporter for
aviation week
is it your assumption that there was a
particular point
in post-world war ii history at which
american presidents successively
concluded that it was no longer possible
to trust the american people
on foreign policy issues that is they
became convinced that there either
wasn't time
or the public wasn't sufficiently
educated that you could generate popular
backing
in support of a war before you actually
went into it
and do you particular do you find a
particular point in time at which that
conclusion was reached
that's a fascinating question and i have
never heard it posed to me
or really anyone else i congratulate i'd
love to discuss it i'd be interested to
know just what led you to that
question because it's a profound
question um
but i do have because i thought about
the subject i i can't answer it
without a lot of thought um
i would say it was not during the war it
was sometime prior to our entry into
world war ii
that president roosevelt who i revered
my father voted for although he was
republican
i was brought up to revere fdr and to a
large extent i still do
but he gave us a precedent in a number
of ways
uh that other presidents have followed
very consciously
to very very great costs and it's
described by the attitude you describe
obviously president roosevelt came to
accept the views of a number of people i
won't identify
at this point too long a lecture who
believed it was essential for us to be
in the european war
and were aware that the american public
was
strongly against our active
participation in the war although not
against are giving some degree of
support to the english or allies
as i understand the isolationist
position in congress
from bruce russet's very interesting
book on that uh the
congressional opposition was not to
giving financial aid
to the british for example but to direct
combat participation in the war
and it almost won so roosevelt was
facing a situation where he felt
strongly in his own
his own mind that the country was wrong
on this
and he somehow had to lead them on i
remember once bill buckley
uh on his program the one time i was on
his program
uh thinking to confound me i was on
trial i just come from the courtroom
he says you talk about a lot about lying
presidential lying
or such a thing says what about fdrs
saying that we had peaceful missions
in the atlantic you know with destroyers
who in fact were carrying on any
submarine operations
against the germans what would you call
that i said well
i'd call it a lie what would you call it
he was very taken aback he
wasn't prepared for that answer he said
well
he says i don't know that i would call
it a lie
i was very young at the time that's what
he said
so i said to him well sometimes when
we're young we know more than we know
later about the difference between lying
and truth
we get out of it but anyway what i'm
saying is i think
that the that i know that that example
is consciously in the minds and often
explicitly referred to
by assistant secretaries of state and
defense
and higher when they are justifying in
their own minds the necessity to lie to
the public
they say after all we wouldn't have
defeated hitler we wouldn't have gotten
into the war without a lot of reception
behind that assumption is the assumption
effectively that democracy doesn't work
well it's not necessarily a
generalization
remember that because it's a specific
situation so the public is wrong here
in this case you know so i have to go
around them certainly that's what
each of these presidents thought about
vietnam they couldn't handle the truth
on doing what is necessary but
they wouldn't support that it's a
specific case but of course you're right
and again
it shows the wisdom behind your question
so of course there's a bureaucratic
mentality
and an elitist mentality but it's not
just parties it doesn't seem to be
limited to the eastern establishment of
the western summer
it's very much a bureaucratic part which
is very anti-democratic
the congress to start with is parochial
uh self-interested politically minded
unlike us who think of the national
interest they think of their little
constituency
drunk as erlickman used to say all the
time total contempt for congress they
drink
all the time now he he had a boss who
had a little problem
but uh the in fact
but the congressmen were drunk
congressmen can't be trusted et cetera
et cetera so
we have to protect the country from
congress and ultimately
from the public from the right wing from
the left wing not they don't worry about
the left wing very much they think you
know it's
ineffective and not very large but the
right wing will make us do things
here's by the way i'll give you a an a a
rationale that i think is very important
that has never been
johnson in effect has never been given
enough credit it does not justify what
he did
but in his mind i'm sure that he and
mcnamara and what they were doing in the
way of bombing
felt that they were on a course that was
protecting the country
from the proposals of the joint chiefs
of staff
who would if they exposed their own
views by resigning
and coming speaking out as one could
might well say they should have done
given their convictions
except that they were military men under
the cmj
if they did that if they exposed
themselves democracy they had reason to
fear
the public will back those catastrophic
proposals those crazy proposals
and let me tell you i agree with johnson
and mcnamara knows
their proposals of the joint chiefs were
crazy they would not have won
they would have risked war with china
which may be what some of them wanted
and that would have been nuclear war so
johnson and the other said we have to
deceive but
we have to follow a course which will
give the joint chiefs enough of what
they want so they won't resign and press
for their proposal
and because it might be supported by the
public will say
well we don't know whether to work or
not let's do it let's win let's get this
over
the public as has been pointed out
thought till very late in the game
win or get out even after tech the mood
was not
get out it was win or get out and a
joint chiefs
some of the people who believe that it
would have won attacks the joint chiefs
for not exposing their views frankly you
know and following that and that has
some merit although
i must say i'm happy to see that
civilian control
was observed constitutionally here i'm
glad they didn't do that
on constitutional grounds and policy
grounds because i thought their policy
was
terrible but johnson then thought and
and to some degree nixon france but
johnson and kennedy
thought i have to lie i need to lie
partly because the the public is so
uninformed and might back
policies that were terrible if they
heard about if they knew they had joint
chiefs backing
if they knew that they might back them
so i have to conceal that
but they were not so they they followed
a middle course of an endless
escalating war that wasn't as bad as the
night chiefs proposed
they did not consider getting out
instead they just did not consider not
because the proposal was not made
the proposal was made and not only by
george ball
but by william bundy assistant secretary
of defense clark clifford
hubert humphrey the vice president gave
that advice to the president 6465.
i knew none of that in the pentagon or
when i read the pentagon papers because
their dovish views were so secret
that i never saw them as special
assistant to the assistant secretary of
defense
so and if it was important not to keep
to keep me from seeing it
it was doubly important not to keep not
to allow the congress to see it or the
president
and so forth and of course it's
conceivable that i would have leaked
them
reliable as i was uh that might have
done it then and that would have been to
the good i wish i wish that it happened
or i might not in which case i'd still
be feeling guilty